hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dream daddy now we
got to get back into this because Joseph
probably wants his play back I think we
get a good at I think we get a ton of
good neighbor points if we bring this
back we're gonna be the best neighbors
during this whole cul-de-sac we're gonna
kick all the other neighbors butts with
kindness Amanda and I step outside shoot
I'm actually not sure which house is his
but hathir a guest is the big one with
all the well-groomed blonde children
sitting in the yard good eye kid
remember we need to make a positive
first impression here keep it light
we walk up to the kids and wave I'm
probably gonna punch one of them in the
face oh they look down look down I'll
just stare at us blankly we just wanted
to return this nice plate and thank you
for the cookies he's definitely our
Joseph kids they all look exactly like
him hey they were really good I mean I
heard they were good I didn't get to eat
any I chuckle nervously okay we're just
gonna set this plate down the ground
real gentle and then back away slowly
right dad
right that's what we're gonna do don't
murder us the kids eyes bore into us if
we scurry away I can feel their gaze on
my back even as we approach our house
need something get my mind off those
Carbon Copy kids I need to rest my eyes
all righty then you've been awake for
what three hours three hours too many I
need my sleep don't do it once do it
right okay as we're walking home I hear
heavy footsteps come up behind us mark
oh I turn around and I'm greeted by a
familiar face jogging up to us oh I know
this guy hello Greg holy wow I haven't
seen Kraken forever it's been too long
dude yeah wow you look great really
great
bro bro ha yeah I cleaned up my act
cleaned up his act are you kidding me
he's ripped Amanda this is my friend
Craig we went to college together we
were roommates for a while to Amanda
dude you probably don't remember me
you're so big now hello
okyou baby oh thank you the last time I
saw you I think you were about her size
this River say Aye River he picks up her
tiny wrist and waves it around river
gurgles happily are you babysitting nah
dude rivers my kid man it has been a
long time feels like one minute we're
rolling up to exams with bad hangovers
and the next we're both fathers where
you been man I was working out in
California and just relocated the
business back to Maple Bay no kiddin
Amanda I just moved to this side of town
house smashley doing I mean Ashley
Ashley is her name she actually still
goes by smashley and uh we got divorced
last year oh dude I'm so sorry it's old
news we take turns carrying taking care
of a river in the twins it's all
copacetic twins you have three kids
ain't life something bro write text and
Craig is a father of three keg stand
Craig oh yeah it was my old college
nickname we got it because he did a lot
of keg stands thank you where you do a
handstand on a keg and then drink from
the keg right he was very good at it Oh
bro I hate to be that guy but I'm in the
middle of my daily jog and I really got
to keep up my heartrate brought river
along for you know resistance training
you jog daily I jog yearly on January
1st when I promise myself I'm a jog
daily for the rest of the year but then
I give up after 30 minutes of would walk
home
dude you should join me sometime god
damn it why's Craig gotta be so much
better than me ah Johnny Go Go Go Go
exercise go for a jog I don't know come
on it'd be fun we could grab breakfast
afterwards catch up we can do a bro
brunch like the good old days all right
sure sounds great I love bro brunch can
we go bro brunch every day great let's
get going that soon I better get moving
good to see you guys Craig gives a
little wave puts his ear back to the
buds back in and jugs off I can't
believe Craig is ripped and has kids I'm
reeling why is Craig so much better than
me why is that the Craig I knew is not
fit to be responsible for any living
thing including and especially himself
one time I watched him drink an entire
jar of marinara sauce for dinner Amanda
he opened up two new jar of marinara
sauce and then he drank it like he was
in new
that normal people do it was unholy and
then I asked him what the hell he was
doing and he said and I quote it's
basically a smoothie bro I mean
technically he's not wrong yeah they say
he's not wrong I guess that is what a
tomato smoothie would be he jogs he was
jogging it's like a totally different
person anyway we better get home I'll
have plenty of time to reflect on how
old I feel later oh don't trust oh okay
manda and I flopped down on the couch
amanda has to shove some empty boxes out
of the way before she can sit huh do bad
we're gonna be putting my stuff right
back into these boxes in a few months
dad it's gonna be okay I'll be fine I
know it's just my little girl it's gonna
be weird not having you around I'll come
visit and I'll text you every day and
I'll take lots of pictures I mean
obviously I'm a photography major you
promise of course are you gonna be okay
by your lonesome come on I'll be fine
I'll get a dog or something or a
boyfriend or whatever a dog look at art
school I'll stay for the dog is that
what it's gonna take
medium-size dog hankerchief around the
neck I get to name it that's what it'll
cost for me to give up mom my dreams I'm
a woman of simple wants and needs
wasn't that the dog that we met in the
park well the dog is a lot cheaper than
College Amanda laughs suddenly a pile of
envelopes slides through the mail slot
speaking of college
Amanda darts over to the envelopes and
shuffles through them she pulls one out
and throws the rest back in the field
this is from the McGowan College Barton
design now opening I'm scared
is this an envelope yeah it's just like
my entire future not a review she takes
a deep breath and rips a letter open
with her teeth we have a letter opener
but okay hold my breath wallah Manders I
start back-and-forth scanning the letter
what does it say the admissions
committee has reviewed your application
blah blah blah um we her face drops is
this a joke we regret to inform you all
that we're unable to offer you admission
to the McGowan colleges oh it's okay
kind of saw it coming I knew I shouldn't
have put that experimental stuff in my
portfolio there
missions officer told me they just want
to see portraits or whatever I pull a
man in for a big hug you're an amazing
photographer I know how much work you
put into your portfolio some other
school is gonna want to snatch you up
for sure yeah I know it's fine
you actually fine are you just saying
that I'm fine really her face says the
opposite but oh [ __ ] and push her on
this Oh before I forget
Mor M appear sleeping over to them so
you need me out of the way because I'm
painfully uncool I would choose more
delicate phrasing but yes cool I can get
my trumpet out we can start the sky band
again well have you know that I
conveniently already have a plan for
tonight so you'll have the new place to
yourself yeah what are you plans plans -
I'm gonna go daddy datin [ __ ] ah I'm
gonna go go clubbing I'm secretly the
mayor of this town
I don't ever you know this a man of the
town needs me I need to perform my
mayoral duties
I must dawn my top out and wear my
monocle so that I may preside over my
mayor stuff I think you're thinking of
the guy from monopoly he was a mayor
right he was not right I'm just kidding
I'm actually going to go dance
tear it up on the dance floor at the
local club watch the game nice which
game you know the game the one that's on
tonight the game then on TV yet
somewhere other than here okay cool
while you do that I'm gonna do drugs and
commit some light arson with the Emmis
I'm concerned you're hanging out with
the wrong crowd
commander shrugs I would have expected
you guys to be up to white-collar crime
at this point maybe money laundering at
the least a street rat pops you're
kidding about doing drugs and crime
right yes dad
just making sure I'll give her a pat on
the head have fun with your sports are
you being sarcastic no making fun of
sports has played out all right then do
some light cleaning around the house and
decide to clear out right before
Amanda's friends arrive before I leave
Amanda stops me hey don't forget that
you have that meeting with my English
teacher tomorrow all right mr. Vega yep
totally remembered I'll be there
okay who's mr. Vega what'd you do oh I
want to know these dad tips they're very
important to me wow I guess I really
didn't think this plan through I'm not
entirely sure where the closest bar is
in a man distill it and show me how to
use the GPS on my phone so I'm just
gonna pick a direction and walk in it
let's go heidy done this way this way I
need I need I need oh cool okay
we're marching marching in the direction
of the game game in the distance
could it be Oh Jim and Kim's that was
Jimmy Kim's a big burn town neon sign
hangs above the tiny dive bar Jimmy
Kim's huh all right the bar is small and
dimly lit the crack pool balls sound in
the backs patrons laugh and joke a
string of multicolored Christmas lights
hover above the bartender I can't tell
if he's Kim or Jim I pull up a seat at
the bar will it be one beer please one
beer for me to watch the game with dear
thing boss the bartender slides me an
old through the good bu ice-cold beer I
take a sip and enjoy the refreshing
taste say are you Jim Kim I'm Neil oh oh
awkwardly turn my attention to the game
which is playing on one of the TV's on
the wall as luck would have it my team
of preference is not only playing but is
currently in the lead which is always a
good thing the brightly colored mascot
which is some kind of an animal does
cartwheels I silently cheer on my
favorite team hoping that I don't get
into any confrontational arguments with
a fan of the opposing team several
people in this bar are wearing the
distinctive colors of the team I dislike
although I believe from their demand or
that like me the passion for their team
is all in good fun
Oh a middle-aged woman holding a nearly
empty wineglass sidles up to the barn
sits uncomfortably close to me hey
sailor oh hello good to see fresh meat
in here I'm Mary come here often oh I
actually just moved into this part of
town today I'm mark by the way you
watching the game yeah my preferred team
is in the lead if they keep this up
they'll win the game with ease oh I love
that team and also I love the game I
love someone who knows their way around
balls
that's me me that's me I'm getting the
impression that she's a little drunk ah
my gala drink seems drunk enough however
I can't drink drink for me
I almost reluctantly signaled the
bartender didn't order marry another
glass of wine
kneel jokes back and forth with Mary
they're clearly friends in this but
clearly isn't her first time doing this
she's dips her glass at me suppose
they've got to keep you company now so
what do you want to know what's the
latest gossip round here you hear any
cool stories about the people around
this town you came to the right brah I'm
an observer I watch people I see
everything know everyone nothing gets
past me Joe
so what I thought you were gonna I
forgot we're we're talking about about
the gossip
you said nothing gets past you alright
I'm also a steel trap confidential to a
fault okay so what else can you tell me
about this part of town it's quiet
that's for sure if you want an idea like
a little life with white picket fences
that's the place to do it but every town
has its secrets you know she takes a sip
of her drink it was a little too ominous
for my tastes she leans in closer do you
like to CERN to learn some of my secrets
oh boy yeah maybe some other time see
yourselves a l'heure see you Mary Mary
saunters off setting her sights on the
newest bar patron to injured
happily watch the game over another beer
the game has gotten close in terms of
points a little too close in what I'm
comfortable with
after a particularly skilled player
scores a number of points for the other
team putting them in the lead I hear an
affirmative grunt from another man at
the bar go team it's the brooding man
from the coffee spoon he sits alone
sipping whiskey watching the game as
well enjoying the game I am now that
we're winning oh we must be rooting for
different teams in my opinion my team is
far superior I have to disagree with
that
based on our win-loss record I'd say
that my team is superior that's where
you're wrong since as it stands right
now my team is beating yours the
conversation ends there and we both go
back to silently rooting for our
respective teams
the game is closed with both sides
playing their hardest to win but in the
end my team prevails quiet Cheers
ripple through the bar I raised a
respectful glass at the man drinking
whiskey he raises his in response an
unspoken truce is formed between us
based on our mutual love for the game he
motions to the bartender who pours two
glasses of whiskey
the man slides one over to me the names
Robert thanks I'm mark you must be new
here Mary already hit on you yeah
Robert chuckles she's a peach well you
picked the best bar in town as slimy as
it is you'll never find a better spot
than Jim and Kim's is there actually a
gym or Kim that runs this place no
that'd be Neil Neil waves from across
the bar good guy Neil not enough Neil's
in this world oh okay you a whiskey
fella or a beer fella beer but I'll
drink most things you like shots
whoo shots fired I don't like him god
that's a dad joke all right
love shots blinkie's baby yeah
thank God oh yeah you're welcome Robert
Knotts daniil who serves up two shots of
whiskey he hands one to me here's to
your health
yeah we take the shots the whiskey burns
going down but I try my hardest to look
tough wait I think this is what making
friends is okay mark this guy's out of
my friendly but I think if i play my
cards right we'll be pals in no time
kenapa manis hand tattoo oh that is very
that's very subtle is rugged good looks
too forward not friendly enough
complement it's cool leather jacket I
think that's just impersonal enough to
start off this conversation hey nice
jacket like your jacket
Thanks been in my family a long time
passed down from the firstborn to
firstborn cursed some would say man this
guy's mysterious and cool way cooler
than I am at least Robert signals to the
bartender for another brown what are you
doing here today well running from the
table
like a badass I'm running from him I got
a boo-boo this morning I met a guy in a
park you had a cute dog but he outdid my
my dad proudness scarred me for life
running from my problems the usual I
like your style he gets a be right back
gotta powder my nose with cocaine never
seen Robert this talkative he must like
you huh I guess so with me what liking
the game and whiskey and all I gotta
admit the Robert as a gruff charm to him
if a guy like that thinks I'm cool then
I really must be
Rober comes back from the bathroom and
grabs his leather jacket we've got to go
home you heading my way Robert and I
leave the bar and find ourselves walking
in the same direction I live in this
cul-de-sac down the way me too
we just finished unpacking today great
place to be good neighbors well some of
them was that we get to Robert's house
which is just a few houses away from
mine he stops and he turns to me I don't
kiss him towel mark sir we do in this
wood Oh what you know do you want to
come inside or not Oh
a wave of realization rushes over me I
blush lay down smooth smile and nod no
thank you
smiling and nod seems like what I would
do
yeah uh-huh okay yeah okay let's do it
Oh follow him Oh Oh God
follow him up to his door he fumbles
with the key for a second and unlocks
door leading me inside the Moho the
moment the door closed behind us he
pushes me up against the wall and kisses
me grabbing to my hips come on whoa
Robert takes my hand and leads me up the
stairs and into what I assume is his
bread room but it's so dark and I can't
see anything but Roberts intense
expression
he gives me again and I can hear
shucking off its jacket I clumsily take
off mine to his hands roam down my chest
suddenly he's tugging at my belt I uh I
don't normally do this do you want to
stop no no good Robert continues to
unbuckle my belt and guides me to the
bed let's have some fun well then that
happened sunlight streams in between the
slats of my blinds my head is pounding I
really overdid it last night wait a
minute this isn't my old house or my new
house oh right I look around for Robert
but find myself alone hello there's a
clatter from the bathroom the doors open
Robert is fully dressed and grabs his
keys
that's fun yeah it was you should go oh
it's certainly not what I was expecting
well uh talk to you later Robert cracks
a smile sure your clothes are over there
I hastily get dressed and show myself
out the Sun is unbearably bright I need
to lie down I start to make my way back
home when I suddenly remember Amanda Oh
rush back home and throw the door up and
something smells delicious Amanda looks
slightly disappointed oh man I was kind
of hoping you've gotten kidnapped then I
was gonna have to come rescue you no I
uh made a friend at the bar last night
and ended up sleeping over
[Music]
they left a little while ago oh you guys
have fun yeah watch the movies it's
snack stole car you know usual sleepover
stuff you teens and your larceny so this
breakfast is cooking what's that all
that there's hash browns and eggs and
bacon can I
yes you can have some breakfast bless
you sweet child my head throbs we gotta
do something about this hangover Amanda
your loving father might have overdone
it last now Oh somebody's hungover
father of the year
you wouldn't happen to have any aspirin
or I've got just the thing
hang on man who runs over to the fridge
and pulls out a jar of pickles man what
I mean I love pickles I [ __ ] love
pickles drink this yep it's what I used
once would assume someone would use I
would also assume that it works pretty
well though I've never tried it before
and won't try it obviously see Amanda
and who gave you alcohol was it one of
the various Emma's in your life dad
chill man I've never had an ounce of
chill in my life and you should know
that by now
you better not be drinking alcohol in
this household ah just drink the juice
it's better work down a sip of the
Tartan juice no more than that way more
than that I mean I assume watch it you I
drink more pickle juice and help myself
to a delicious breakfast than Amanda has
graciously allowed me to partake in
after inhaling some hash browns and
dunking several pieces of bacon into my
runny egg yolk I'm starting to feel a
little better
Amanda grabs her backpack in keys will
help I gotta get to class
don't forget the meeting with mr. Baig
oh okay he said it was important lobby
ah I'll be there knock him dead kiddo
always do we do our secret handshake and
cheese off I get a little work done at
home before I glanced at my watch and
see it's almost time for the meeting I
hop in the shower change clothes and
head on my way still a little hungover
hey burden hand is worth better than to
be okay I arrived at a man to school and
check in the front desk they give me a
bride or and visitor sticker and send me
on my way I feel pretty haggard after
not brushing my teeth or showering but
hopefully no one will notice check my
watch and a ravu leave to see that i'm
only two minutes late wait was it room
103 or 108 i spot a youth standing at
his locker and approached him for help
excuse me do you know where mr. Vegas
classroom is the youth turns around and
looks me up and down if he's flying two
eyes
excuse you hey he's got my hairstyle
goddamnit if they had that about I would
have gone come on kid I'm late for a
meeting mr. who mr. Vega I don't know
have you tried the exit okay wise guy
you gotta help me or not fine laughter
canvas room I have the stairs and walk
around unable to find mr. Vegas class
anywhere after a couple minutes of
searching ahead back downstairs
that punk youth sent me on a wild goose
chase
we get back to where that low-rent
geared wave is standing fully ready to
give him peace of mind mind when
suddenly a head pops out of the
classroom next to his locker Oh Lucien
don't you have a third period to get to
Oh fine mr. Vega huh Wow
I'm officially 10 minutes late I glare
at him as he walks away we're not cool
you must be mark this periods almost
over do you mind waiting in the back mr.
Vega leads me in and I take a seat in
one of the comically small students
desks in the back I might get stuck Hoss
all right where are we now who can tell
me about the unreliability of the
Meritor and JD Salinger's catch her in
the wrong yes Colin Colin stands up and
does the thing where he blows into the
crook of his Bell bow to make a fart
noise the whole class erupts in laughter
ha ha hee hee ho ho all right all right
everybody very funny Colin please sit
down
Holden Caulfield is an unreliable
narrowly narrator in the sense that the
bell for the end of beard rings all the
students immediately get up and make the
break for the dough ha hmm
or not I guess mr. Vega turns to me in
sighs middle schoolers right don't you
teach high schoolers both you know
budget cuts right aah
thanks so much for coming in no problem
mr. Vega
please call me Hugo Hugo Vega what a day
I don't normally do these impromptu
parent-teacher meetings but as I'm sure
you know a man is a very bright student
and I'm concerned about her recent
behavior what's going on manna has never
been the most engaged student but I know
she cares Risa
though she's been falling behind she's
not completing assignments and has been
doing rather poorly on tests I'd
normally chalk it up to senioritis but
this is strange I thought a man who
always shared everything with me it
hadn't even crossed my mind that
something might be wrong hmm I just want
to ask is everything okay home oh we
just moved well we just moved recently
but it was only to the other side of
town and Amanda was more excited about
it than I was
see if you can talk to her about I know
she values you a great deal and would
appreciate your guidance if she keeps
heading down this road I know how
important art school is to her and I
would hate to see her miss out on a
scholarship money that she clearly
deserves I'll make sure to talk to
Amanda thanks for letting me know who
you anytime on my way out I stopped
thinking for a moment I turn to Hugo hey
Hugo
ah yes they ever catch that ride oh boy
hmm yes oh nice nice
I leave the classroom and make my way
out of the school I'm still a little bit
in shock than Amanda was able to hide
this so well for me she always has been
a sort of force for such positivity in
my life especially after we lost her
father Amanda must be done with classes
for the day by now I'm sure she would
appreciate a ride home maybe I can talk
to her about what's going on carpooling
Amanda hops in the passenger long-long
lady young lady young lady so did you
have an awesome gossiping time about me
mr. vagin and I actually gossiped about
our celebrity crushes so you talked
about Mario Batali the whole time I was
it was a very productive meeting pretty
hungry can we grab some dinner sure
thing see let's go to the mall let's go
to the mall today the mall does that
sound good to you yeah sure why the mall
geez can of dad take his daughter to the
mall we buy me things we'll buy you a
thing singular one thing sounds like a
deal to me
we're driving silence for a short while
Amanda plays a game on her phone I
should say something you know sometimes
when a kid gets older they find that
they have to keep things hidden from
their parents and that's okay
because some
that's what kids do and that's okay but
also sometimes it's good to have parents
perspectives on things and stuff because
you know maybe the parents also have
dealt with similar situations in their
life given that they have or they are
older and have been through things such
as that and maybe they're a little
cooler than you give them credit for
anyway what I'm trying to say is that
it's good to share love you have you
been reading my tweets you have Twitter
hmm what never mind
lock screen mr. Vega said you haven't
been participating in the class and then
you're not turning things in well I'm
fine Bob senioritis and all that I
thought you liked mr. vigus class it's
fine he's fine we pull up to a stoplight
and I i Amanda she's still texting just
I want you to know that you can talk to
me about anything I can tell that
whatever it is she doesn't want me
knowing about it that's frustrating I
heard Emma ours going to that fancy art
school in California
that's exciting yep you guys aren't
going to the same school yeah Manny
keeps texting she stifles a laugh what's
so funny it's I love memes are you
texting Noah who's Noah my friend does
he go to your school yep do you like oh
I can't believe you would I mean jeez
why would you Oh gross sorry sorry I'm
just asking miss protests too much
daddy's just my friend cousin girl's
gonna be friends he's my friend okay
it's going well well good talk love you
kiddo
guess the conversations over to the mall
in it's okay to cry if you're feeling
sad we arrived at the mall big indoor
shopping center with a couple different
floors it's kind of dead but that
doesn't stop a mall security guard from
yelling at a group of loitering let's
eat something disgusting for dinner oh
yeah
language Missy heck yeah better
what's wrong with ell we approach the
food court and evaluate our options it's
breezy restaurant after greasy
restaurant my heart burns just looking
at the menus nobody hey looks happy to
be here are you in the mood for bread
dipped in sugar or bread with cheese on
it you just want me to inject some fat
directly into your blood I extend my
hand or would you do me the honor of
sharing some nachos takes my hand with a
grin you make me the happiest cheesie's
girl live we order a giant pile of chips
and unnaturally orange cheese from very
unenthusiastic and possibly stoned
teenager we take a seat at the rickety
table and dig in these are bad he's
really bad but also strangely delicious
we have to eat through the pain we enjoy
the fluorescent cheesy goodness together
until we're all out of nachos
something's been bothering me for a
while can you explain me I called it
memes which meme all of the memes man
decides a plain blazer header and dad is
complicated see memes are inside jokes
shared by a bunch of people to get less
funny the more people do it through the
problem is and by the time the mean gets
to you dad if all of us used have
already done the joke to death what's
worse is that is that movies and TVs and
video games will try to jump in on a
meme train but just based on how long it
takes to make them the mean will be long
dead by the time it comes out so it just
dates it and it isn't funny oh [ __ ] what
up oh [ __ ] what up dad please anyway
changing the subject where to now
want to go to that goth store what you
know the one that's all black and tries
to establish itself as an anti
establishment despite being the exact
representation of the establishment I
don't know what sorry you're talking
about you know the one where you can buy
gene Watson this basically saw a lot of
people that fought though hard again the
punk and hardcore movement at 70s and
80s
dude you got to be more specific one
where you threw up in that one time a
man runs into the store with me trailing
behind or she makes a beeline for the
back there it is you can still see the
outline kinda I'm so proud
Amanda speech speech speech speech all
right I'll do it if you stop chanting
man it stops immediately clear my throat
thank you all for joining us here today
to commemorate an historic moment that
would forever shape history on a day
very much like today some five years ago
our very own Amanda and it biere too
much blue raspberry slushy in an outing
to the mall after begging her father to
take her to dad Gotham beyond to buy
rainbow suspenders she proceeded to
throw up all over the display of My
Chemical Romance merchandise her loving
father then had to pay for said
merchandise which to this day remains
among our positions thank you
command is moved she begins clapping
slow at first then faster and more
vigorously several other patrons turn
their heads one of them also starts
clapping oh hey Jane wallets while a man
of busies herself looking at band
t-shirts I try to find something of
other interest to me not much for a dad
to do in dead gallon dead Gotham beyond
I should look at ironic mugs who doesn't
like a good ironic mug I'm suddenly
stricken by existential fear there's
only one number-one dad why are there so
many mugs here to say that this whole
time I thought I was the only one if I'm
not number one where do I place the
global dad ranking charts I have work to
do look it's very important to me over
here a stifled argument at a cash
register an older gentleman is carrying
a garment and showing it at a to afford
looking cashier with pink hair I can see
that don't know what to tell you dude I
just work here listen when I bought this
online the website said this blouse was
Victorian inspired however when I
received it it clearly held the
trademark of the Edwardian dressage do
you want to coupon I can give you a
coupon will you leave if I give you a
coupon they'll manage of present people
have to know what they're buying I am
the manager I see well it would seem
that I've outstayed my welcome today
shall keep your superiors will receive a
strongly worded letter by post
oh dude the man whirls around and storms
out he's literally coattails and
trailing behind him I can't tell if
they're Victorian inspired or Edwardian
in nature manta trots up to me with the
t-shirt in her hand oh boy
here it goes hey Dad Tron 5000 yes I'll
buy for you thanks Lisa it's the only
one that's done it bluff [ __ ] on the
counter and grins at the cashier I love
your hair
cashier says nothing in rings Amanda up
radiating hatred a hand over 20 so what
was that guy's deal
cashier rolls her eyes so hard I'm
worried she'll pull something that's
Damien he's in here all the time he's
obsessed with Victorian fashion or one
or Dan's man or a bag and it's clear the
conversation is over
and make our way out of the store and
head home and get some rest man and I
sit on the couch trying to find
something to watch over the bowls of ice
cream cool long-haul paranormal ice road
ghost truckers is on your favorite right
oh hell yes they have to make it over
the Canadian Tundra before the ice road
melts but they're also hunting ghosts
also the trucks are haunted there's an
episode I've already seen but it's one
of the best Calum Flint dog-bone twin
brother truck driving a Coast ghost
hunting duo find themselves in great
peril yet oh no the ghosts done got out
control of the truck I can't steer among
them they're damn ice roads let me use
this EVP meter to try and communicate
with the spirits
almost got it
if you listen carefully it sounds like
they're saying you're gonna die that's
because we are the episode ends in a man
to excuse herself to start arguments on
the internet I stay up a little longer
and curious about the exploits of Callum
and Flint dog-bone after their
disastrous ice road accident afterwards
I crawl into bed and get a good night's
sleep
Oh dreaming of Daddy liquor before beef
you're in the clear alright so I I'm
gonna I'm gonna end this episode here
we've had a fulfilling day a lot of
stuff has happened and we're starting to
accelerate our entry into dad hood but
before that we've got a long way to go
in a lot more dad's to meet
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think of
this down the comments whoa I'm having a
wonderful time this game it is so
charming I love it so much so thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]